okay what up guys welcome to the just
pearly things youtube channel i'm not
even gonna do an intro today because
i have something to say for the women
that watch my channel
because i keep hearing
this one phrase over
and over and over again
women will talk about their kid right
and when they ask okay how how did this
happen
oh
it just
happened
how
how how did that just happen because
okay
i just don't understand
how we have what like 300 billion forms
of birth control
are y'all still out here accidentally
getting pregnant so this is my message
to women if you get pregnant okay
it's your own fault
i'm not even gonna blame the men for
this one okay not men hear me out y'all
should all
rap it okay
don't don't give crazy girls this power
but ladies
you can get an iud
you can get a million forms of birth
control and let's say let's say you
don't even want to do that
you can make the guy
wear a condom
do we forget you can track your cycle
like i just don't understand
how all of you
are accidentally
just happened it happening to make a
whole ass human life
that
is gonna
i don't know affect the next 20 years of
your existence
and it just happens
ladies it i don't even put this on the
men it is your own damn fault if you get
pregnant
all right get an iud track your cycle
wear a condom and subscribe please
that's it that's my that's my rant for
today